so for all three of you the Western is
such an American genre but you think of
Shane or high noon or The Searchers it's
been a while since westerns have really
been in the mix so when you heard about
this when they came to and you said a
Western what would you think they need
an Indian I was very excited I like to
do period pieces and that's what I
thought it was going to be and then I
found that it wasn't and I loved it I
just loved it I liked the fact that it
said in Texas and I'm a Texan and I like
the way it portrayed Texans I just I
really like to feel even though it
wasn't filmed in Texas that was a cried
it was not if it was close it was I can
see it from your house practically
actually the the original title of the
film was command area which is a region
that the Comanche kind of ruled over
which spilled over into what's now
crossed over into New Mexico so it's we
were pretty close to the to the eastern
coast there New Mexico and Clovis Katie
what did you think well I am originally
from the South I mean from Pensacola
Florida originally and all my family's
from Louisiana but I'm not from Texas
but I completely had an unbelievable
connection to it immediately you know
the script was let's just put it this
way it wasn't Howard Hawks it was kind
of underwritten how did you approach
that I mean was it a challenge was it
kind of scary to think there's so much
space in this for me to do something
really great or maybe screw up I think
gala probably could answer that better
than I could because I was just on and
sassy now so yeah but I think Gil had
those really wonderful moments where he
was making such a connection without
saying a word I
there was this portrayed in the film
which I thought was wonderful
we don't have to talk all the time there
was so much shown so so many motions so
many feelings that were shown without
speaking a word and so I think he could
probably maybe answer that a little bit
better than I could I won't have the
green beans yeah I that was an
interesting opportunity to kind of flush
out these characters and more
importantly the chemistry between them
because you got two sets of partners you
have two genetic brothers and then you
had the Texas Rangers so a lot of it was
already on the script but then the rest
of it got filled in with the with the
dynamics between the characters so it
was important for me to spend as much
time I could with Jeff and to kind of
get to know him and then the the
connection we had together was music you
know I play guitar
Jeff plays guitar so any time that we
weren't working we were jamming which
really kind of lent itself for this
improvisational kind of style for
ourselves to cross over into the act
tonight and not Jeff felt that that way
too it's an incredible opportunity when
you are given the gift to be able to
come into a character but be under the
direction of David McKenzie who was
quite miraculous for me being able to he
trusted me so it was from the very
beginning of the audition process I
walked in and they said you called back
and I said amazing and so then he I
walked in and he said I go what would
you like me to do he goes well what are
you feeling I said I want to go with my
instincts and he said please do he said
just do that and I did it and he said
that's exactly it and I said it's
wonderful to meet you and then next
thing I know I'm in Clovis New Mexico so
yeah um Gil there there were so many
potentials for falling into cliche here
the two partners and the two gangsters
how did you make that partnership so
distinctive especially when your
camaraderie was sort of insult based he
was making fun of you you were making
fun of him yeah you know that that still
gets back to Taylor Sheridan this this
amazing rider and there was a bit of
improvisation there we actually did a
three hour improvisation David McKenzie
the director who was Scottish by the way
you're wondering how he brought this
sense of the Western to you as snow
strongly as he has growing up in western
Scotland yeah but it was important and
Jeff and I had talked about it because
we were worried that his character was
really gonna be coming off somewhat of
an [ __ ] you know but then we
reflected on the dynamics of even our
own family members and how much teasing
can be cruel you know if you just know
those buttons to push so I it was also
an opportunity because it's only the
only really ethnic character in the
movie and him being native and and part
Mexican
I drew upon the culture to kind of have
an understanding of what this man was
going through losing his wife two years
before that you know being pushed out of
a job that he identified himself with
and and from the native culture you know
there's it's compassion it's
understanding it's respect so I thought
that that was important for my character
kind of share that but it was playful at
the same time
Margaret you were such a scene stealer
in No Country for Old Men or Lone Ranger
did they come to you for this role or
did you hear about it and say let me in
know my my agent had submitted me and
David said that when and I assured on
tape and he said that when he saw my
tape then you know he he knew that's
what he wanted and I have to say that I
kind of this was my mom my mother my
mother supported herself her mother and
three daughters waiting tables and she
was a straw
long Texas woman she was sassy she was
funny and she was serious about
supporting her family and so I kind of
drew on what my mom was what I had seen
with my mom and I read the script and I
just fell in love with it
the I I have to admit that I even cried
when I read the script because I thought
this was such great writing when you
have good writing you have as so many of
you know when you have good people that
you're working with that are so generous
like like the two that I was working
with they they just let me have it and
director like David the direction he
gave me was move a half an inch over
this way for the camera
he said just let me run with it and when
you have all of those things working for
you it just don't get no better than
that and so I fell in love with this
character I fell in love with the script
and to me this is a love story as much
as it is anything else
it's the love between these two men the
two older men
it's the love between the two brothers
it in that respect it's a beautiful
story and then the photography oh my
that was that was just great I oughta
get her I just loved the film it
reminded me a little of last picture
show that kind of Texas light did it
look authentic to you as a Texan there
well at the the script the lines lent
themselves so well two things that I've
heard and said all of my life we were
talking about this earlier this evening
about the name of the film when it was
Komachi area it really didn't
it it didn't play and because most of us
don't know the background to that word
but hell or high water come hell or high
water you're gonna do that come hell or
high water I'm gonna do that come hell
or high water somebody said what does
that mean I say it means the
determination but the hell or high water
just so beautifully fit everything that
was going on and and Katie how did you
when you saw the script and you were
flushing out the role for yourself and
thought about the title how did you come
to that same kind of because you were
waitress two very different kind of
waitress but it says something about the
kind of people who are in this film and
the kind of people who are in this
country completely they represent I it
was an unbelievable gift to be first
being able to give be given the script
and I read it and immediately I cried
like Miss market it and it's just you
immediately feel for those people that
are trying to work a nine-to-five job
every single day and are trying to get
ahead somehow and trying to hold on to
the what they can do every day and
living from paycheck to paycheck and I
just put myself in that world and it was
so refreshing because to be able to give
in you know that we'll be able to read
the script of Taylor which was just
absolutely incredible it has been so
long since I've been able to read
something so wonderful written like a
play like it was a it was an aspect of a
play you know on Broadway and so yeah it
was I immediately responded to it just
like this mark and and Gil for you was
it
reading it was it your character was it
the whole ensemble nature of it that oh
it was definitely the script it always
starts with a script and it was so
flushed out and it had you know these
these elements to it and especially the
cycle of of what has still kind of
continued on to a contemporary days now
after a the the recession it was so
timely because you know a lot of people
still haven't recovered from that but to
understand the history of it and how
this cycles gone back you know and and
people may be a forgotten the native
loss you know when that land was taken
and now it's happening to them and it's
not armies that are doing it you know
it's the economics and it's the
institutions that we feel so helpless by
so I think that that resonated for me
but the Pat the banter and the the
opportunity to kind of find the love
between you know Jeff's character my
character with this banter that they had
and then the revelation of what those
things that were written we're really
saying these thank Katy Mixon Gil
Birmingham and Miss Margaret Bowman